isabelle morini-bosc vous êtes fait
draguer suis largué au milieu d'un lac
heures qu'est ce qui s'est passé un
homme du sud
alors c'était l'année de mon bac de
français non qui à 75 ans comme ça
devait pas lire gso lyon j'étais c'était
très heureux c'est très flatteur parce
qu'il y avait un garçon 20 m 95 kg était
basketteur qui s'appelait jean et qui me
courtisait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
car bien évidemment je n'avais pas la
gueule que j'ai ouïe est magnifique
[Applaudissements]
mais ce tir mais je me sens super
complet que c'est parce que j'étais
frisé quand même temps alors que c'était
la mode des cheveux raides et donc je
les cache et les gens n'avaient une
énorme masse mais caché sous un banc
mana et ce garçon mais dont je vais te
faire une déclaration splendide sur un
lac dans un bateau si tu mets tes vrais
cheveux et je me suis dit merde pas
arrivé mais je me pose est est une
copine qui était coiffeuse me prête une
superbe paire 2 coeurs avec les cheveux
longs comme ça mais magnifique que je
suis toujours avec le petit est mort
mana ou sur le bateau mathlouthi short
tout emballé dessus manif leur faire des
pauses en 2012 on peut faire des procès
alors uni lieu du petit lac de savoir
lac d'aiguebelette où s'entraîne
l'équipe d'aviron
[Applaudissements]
le ring il a fait ce beau être très
grand et très bien bâti tout point de
vue et aveugle
oui à la pub je dépanne lourdeur l'a
sauvé de l'époque c'était vraiment photo
à
et encore c'est vrai alors ça elle alla
réseau la raison reste on a droit aussi
et donc il prend la ras il donne un
grand coup ne fracasse la moitié du
visage et surtout il emporte la perruque
je me suis retournée comme une comme
avec toutes mes petites frisure et là il
m'a regardé mais j'avais besoin d'être
un bon c'est fait ah non je peux tout
pardonner sauf qu'on manque pas de lui
planter n'importe les rames et comme
collagène des hôtels sont géniales
j'ai commencé à ramer non
[Applaudissements]